concludes the member questioning
representativeness you're recognized for
any concluding remarks well act one of
today's circus is over for those of you
who have been watching it at home
the Democrats are no closer to
impeachment than where they were three
years ago in the process they've the
Department of Justice FBI State
Department elements within the IC the IC
IG have all suffered long-term damage
the Democrats can continue to put to
poison the American people with this
nonsense we set hair all morning without
any evidence for impeachment which would
be a very serious crime high crime and
misdemeanors as says in the Constitution
no such thing policy disagreements and
the Democrats failure to acknowledge
their involvement in the 2016 election I
would say it's astonishing but that
would be putting too little emphasis on
their actions that I yield back the
balance of my time
I thank the gentleman I want to thank
our witnesses today there's Williams
Colonel VIN Minh both of you for your
service to the country for your
testimony here today and I just want to
address briefly some of the evidence you
presented as well as others thus far in
the impeachment inquiry first of all I
want to join my colleagues in a thanking
you colonel VIN Minh for your military
service and I should tell you that
notwithstanding all of the questions you
got on why didn't you go talk to your
supervisor why didn't you go talk to mr.
Morrison why did you go to the National
Security lawyer as if there's something
wrong with going to the national
security lawyer are you aware that we
asked mr. Morrison whether he went to
the National Security lawyer right after
the call and that he did and are you
were also that we asked him well if you
had this problem with Colonel VIN Minh
not going to you instead of the lawyer
naturally you must have gone to your
supervisor in Euros answer was he didn't
go to his supervisor either he went
directly to the National Security
Council lawyer so I hope my colleagues
will give him the same hard time for not
following his chain to command that he
complained about with you apparently the
president may attack you and has others
on right-wing TV might attack you and
they have but I thought you should know
and maybe you know already that this is
what the former chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff had to say about you
Colonel van Minh he is a professional
competent patriotic and loyal officer he
has made an extraordinary contribution
to the security of our nation in both
peacetime and combat I'm sure your dad
is proud to hear that my colleagues have
tried to make the argument here today
and we've heard it before that the
president was just interested in
fighting corruption
that's our goal fighting corruption in
Ukraine this terribly corrupt country
the problem of course with that is
there's no evidence of the president
trying to fight corruption the evidence
all points in the other direction the
evidence points in the direction of the
president inviting Ukraine to engage in
the corrupt act of investigating a u.s.
political opponent ambassador Jovanovic
was known as a strong fighter of
corruption so what does the president do
he recalls her from her post ambassador
ivanovich in fact was at a meeting
celebrating other anti-corruption
fighters including a woman who had acid
thrown in her face on the day she was
told to get on the next plane back to
Washington
you prepared talking points for the
president's first conversation with
szalinski he's supposed to talk about
rooting up corruption if this president
had such a deep interest in rooting out
corruption in Ukraine surely he would
have brought it up in the call but of
course we now know that he did not
we then see Rudy Giuliani not fighting
corruption but asking for an
investigation of the Biden's and
i colleagues say well maybe he was
acting on his own even though he says
he's acting as the president's lawyer
maybe he was really acting on his own
but the two investigations that Rudy
Guiliani wanted come up in the meeting
you participate in on July 10th at the
White House when a Boston ambassadors
Sandlin brings up the Biden's in
Brisbane in 2016 tells the Ukrainians
who want that meeting the White House
you got to do these investigations now
they would say ambassador Solomon was
acting on his own but that doesn't quite
work either because we have the call
record from July 25th which the
president was forced to release in which
the president doesn't bring up
corruption he doesn't say how those
anti-corruption courts going or great
work in the Rada of course not
what does the president say I want you
to invest them investigate the Biden's
and this debunk conspiracy theory pushed
by Vladimir Putin that also helps me in
my reelection so much for fighting
corruption the message to Ukraine the
real message to Ukraine our US policy
messages don't engage in political
investigations the message from the
president however was the exact opposite
do engage in political investigations
and do it for my reelection and it's
also made clear they want the White
House meeting and ultimately if they
want 400 million in US aid this is what
they have to do the only lament I hear
from my colleagues is it wasn't
successful they got caught they didn't
get the put of conversations and they
still had to release the money now they
still haven't the White House meeting
but they had to release the money
because a whistleblower blew the whistle
whistleblower the president wants to
punish and because Congress announced it
was doing investigations and very soon
thereafter the president was forced to
lift the hold on the aid they argue well
this makes it this makes it okay that it
was a failed effort to bribe Ukraine a
failed effort to extort Ukraine that
doesn't make it better it's no less
odious because it was discovered and it
was stopped and we have courageous
people like yourself who come forward
who reports the
things will do what they should do who
have a sense as you put it Colonel of
duty of duty not to the person of the
present but to the presidency and to the
country and we thank you for that at the
end of the day I think this all comes
back to something we heard from another
career foreign service officer just last
Friday in a conversation he overheard
with the president in a restaurant in
Ukraine in which the president not Rudy
Giuliani not anyone else the president
I'd states wanted to know are they gonna
do the investigations this is the day
after that July 25th call are they gonna
do the investigations and he's assured
by ambassador Solomon they're gonna do
it and what is someone relate to this
foreign service officer obviously hangs
up that call the president doesn't give
a expletive about Ukraine he only cares
about the big things that help his
personal interests that's all you need
to know and it isn't just about Ukraine
of course Ukraine is fighting our fight
against the Russians against their
expansionism that's our fight - that's
our fight - at least we thought so in a
bipartisan basis that's our fight -
that's why we support Ukraine with a
military aid that we have well the
president may not care about it but we
do we care about our defense we care
about the defense of our allies and we
darn well care about our constitution we
are adjourned I please ask the the
audience to allow the witnesses and the
members who have to go vote to leave
first
well that concludes this session of the
impeachment inquiry the US president
Donald Trump two witnesses have been
testifying here for the past few hours
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Vint Minh
and Jennifer Williams now both were
listening in on Donald Trump's phone
call to Ukraine's president in July
which is at the heart of this inquiry
both have testified that his request to
Ukraine to investigate the Biden's was
improper
now much of the questioning revolved
around who the two witnesses may have
spoken to particularly the lieutenant
colonel VIN Minh who said that he'd
spoken to someone in the intelligence
community now during the hearing House
Intelligence Committee Chairman Adam
Schiff had to interrupt those questions
to protect patek potentially the
whistleblowers identity you're here to
answer questions and you're here under
subpoena so you can either answer the
question or you can plead the fifth on
behalf of my client we are following the
rule of the committee rule of the chair
with regard to this issue and this does
not call for an answer that is invoking
the fifth or any theoretical issue like
that the following the ruling of the
chair
what counselor what ruling is I could
interject counsel is correct
whistleblower has the right
statutory right to anonymity these
proceedings will not be used to out the
whistleblower let's go now - hi - Joe
Castro who's on Capitol Hill and hardly
there are three words that really delet
doubt during that testimony one is
improper unusual and political takers
through it so far
right and all of those adjectives you
just said Stan were used by today's
witnesses to describe their reaction to
hearing the phone call in July when
Trump asked the president of Ukraine to
open investigations into Trump's
political adversaries in the US and
today's two witnesses were both national
security experts on Ukraine and the
narrative that they laid out is this
they said prior to that phone call there
was a meeting of the White House between
Ukrainian and US officials in which the
Ukrainians were explicitly told that
they had to provide this investigation
or else their President Vladimir
zolensky
would not be invited to the White House
something that he deeply coveted then of
course we have the phone call in itself
in which Solinsky still at the time not
knowing that there was also 400 million
dollars a security aid that was being
withheld he thanked Trump for helping
Ukraine in its defence against Russia
and Trump responds asking for a favor
those investigations into Joe Biden and
the Democrats then you fast-forward a
little over a month when then it's
explicitly communicated to Ukrainian
aides that it's not only the White House
meeting that is being leveraged for this
investigation to the Biden's but also
that security aid that asked made by
Gordon Sandlin the US ambassador to the
EU these are things that the witnesses
today testify to and but and you can see
that the president has denied that there
was any sort of link between the
security aid and the investigations and
Republicans rather than focusing on
evidence that would prove the president
right in that they're focusing attacks
on the process as you just heard trying
to discredit the whistleblower in
attacking today's witnesses as well
saying they refuse to answer questions
about the whistleblowers identity when
of course US law protects that person's
identity from being made open to the
public how do you thank you we're gonna
go to White House correspondent Kimberly
halket who's going to join us now that
the Republicans on this committee the
attitude was really summed up by devin
earnest the the ranking republican at
the amber he said
act one of today's circus is over
the strategy here Kimberly is to
ridicule this we've seen this from
Donald Trump attack the witnesses is it
an effective strategy well they would
argue that they're really in essence
they have been relegated to this
strategy because they make the argument
that the Democrats who are in control of
the House of Representatives have not
permitted all of their witnesses have
not always permitted them to ask the
line of questioning that you would
typically see in a normal sort of due
process trial so that's the
counter-argument in all of this and when
you talk about the circus or the drama
or the performance well all of these
Republicans are performing for an
audience of one we do know the u.s.
president Donald Trump despite saying in
the past that he hasn't bothered to
watch these hearings this time came out
forcefully saying he is watching very
carefully he did continue to attack the
process as unfair as his Republican
congressman colleagues have done as well
as well as a female congresswoman but he
also believed that they were doing
genuinely a good job you have a kangaroo
court headed by little shifty chef where
we don't have lawyers
we don't have witnesses we don't have
anything and yet I just got to watch and
the Republicans are absolutely killing
it they are doing so well because it's
us it's a scam it's a big scam they're
doing something that the founders never
thought possible and the founders didn't
want and they're using this impeachment
hoax for their own political gain and
the argument that has been made is that
what Democrats have been trying to do is
undo the results of the 2016 US election
that well this is the first impeachment
inquiry there have been votes in the
past on the floor of the House of
Representatives to impeach the president
dating back to the very first years of
his presidency so now moving forward the
argument also is is the impact this is
having on the president's health not
only is he undergoing this now
impeachment inquiry but prior to that it
was the probe into whether or not his
2016 campaign
colluded with russia under special
counsel robert muller in fact these
concerns about the president's healthy
impact on it reached a bit of a
crescendo over the weekend on Saturday
when he went to the hospital and this
was not put on the public calendar for
the president speculating in fact that
he may have had some chest pains
potentially a heart attack well the US
president talked about that as well from
inside the White House once again
discrediting the media as he has from
the beginning day one of his presidency
saying that the press is sick and
dangerous a corrupt media I hope they
get their act together also assuring the
public that he was completely fine
Kimberly thank you for that let's
discuss this further now with Jeffery
capper service who is the director of
political studies that niskin and center
and author of rule and ruin the downfall
of moderation and destruction of the
Republican Party he joins us from
Washington DC nice to have you with us
sir both of these witnesses were on in
in on the July telephone call between
President Trump and President Solinsky
both of them raised concerns and took
those concerns to a higher level I want
to get your assessment of what you heard
today the quality and the strength of
their evidence and the credibility of
the two witnesses I think both witnesses
came across as credible on the other
hand I'm not sure it matters in the
broad political theater that has become
the impeachment hearings one of the
phenomena about political life in the
United States right now is that it has
become intensely tribal hmm and if you
are part of one tribe you see almost
anything the other side is doing as
false and wrong and harmful to the
country and in that sense it doesn't
matter how credible the witnesses were
Republicans are bounded and determined
to see them as part of a deep state
conspiracy against the President and
therefore they simply won't credit
anything that they say and to that end
questions were directed specifically at
them and their credibility both were
asked if they were never Trump as and
particularly the tenant Colonel vinden
questioned about his links to Ukraine
about a job offer to become defense
minister in Ukraine questions about
where there he
had leaked information all of this
trying to discredit him to what extent
is that an effective strategy in terms
of playing to that that hardcore
Republican base who see this as a
democratic conspiracy I think it
probably is effective on the part of
Republicans to paint these witnesses as
part of a deep state plot and I think
that they would be blamed by not only
the president but by the base if they
didn't put up a kind of ferocious
argument against the entire proceedings
however there's a bigger question as to
how this will play out politically in
the long run whether in fact attacking
immigrants whether attacking naturalized
citizens of foreign backgrounds whether
attacking people who have fought and
bled in the service of their country in
the United States military will backfire
on the Republicans politically there was
something else it was rise today and
that is the allegations there at the
heart of this the allegations against
Joe Biden's son Hunter and his
connections to the energy company in
Ukraine which really so much of this
revolves around both of the witnesses
said that there is potentially an
appearance here of a conflict of
interest in questions were raised again
about whether Hunter Biden should I
should be forced to testify here what's
your thoughts on that you know I think
there's no doubt that it looks bad to a
large segment of the American people
when the offspring of prominent
politicians get a cushy job for which
they are evidently qualified and these
suspicions are raised manifold when it's
a job with a foreign company
particularly in a state known for
corruption like Ukraine on the other
hand there have been no independently
verified allegations that hunter Biden
did anything wrong that he broke any
laws whatsoever whether of the United
States or of the Ukraine or that Joe
Biden has had any kind of untoward
action with regard to either burr yzma
the company that employed his son or the
Ukrainian government so I think the
attempt on the part of the Republicans
here is to create the appearance that
where there's smoke there must be fire
if this looks a little bad if this looks
maybe a little unethical it probably was
even unlawful Jeffrey kappa service
appreciate you joining us on the program
thank you thank you